let me first start by saying how much I
loved this movie it is fantastic and the
thing for me is I think Scott's
screenplay is probably the best I've
seen on screen this year it's brilliant
and informative and it's not stupid it
never talks down to the audience as
actors you've read many many scripts
what is it like reading something like
this for the first time you're right and
and the incredible thing about reading
something called the torture report is
you go oh boy this is gonna be dry as
yesterday's toast and you start reading
and you're realizing oh this isn't just
a little litany of fact after fact after
fact and it's not this hack job this
partisan hack job it's actually a
incredibly compelling story about how
our government when it is applied
correctly can work and how when it is
abused can not work and in in a world
where it's in the conventional wisdom
seems to say that the government is bad
this this says like actually there are
people in the government that do do
their jobs and then when they're
presented with something that is morally
questionable or illegal they actually
say I'm not doing that so it's it's a
nice change of pace from what we're
currently seeing and in the the
conventional wisdom of government which
is deny double down and and make fun of
the people that are accusing you of
something even when all of the facts
stated you're you're wrong
you can't take a Sharpie to this one
like it's just it's just the truth and
it's done it's cited and the documented
completely for you readings ripped oh I
thought was incredibly compelling I very
as you said very taut the narrative is
very strong and yet you do get an
incredible amount of information making
a political movie that has a lot of
heart and guts to it is very hard and I
feel like Scott had had that kind of
baked in from the very beginning and
it's about people who broke the law and
then it's about people who followed the
rule of
and all of it is factual it nothing is
based on trying to tell a story that's
slanted in one way or another in fact we
have an annotated document that Dan
Jones created that basically backs up
everything in the film so in a time when
we're sort of inundated with information
we don't know how much is true we don't
know what what is being doctored or what
is propaganda its truth matters as they
say and this really does matter it
matters that the Americans broke the law
and they were secretly torturing people
in prisons where people were ferreted
around the world into these secret
prisons the State Department's of these
countries our state department wasn't
even informed in some cases that this
was going on so all of this when this
was uncovered was very explosive but
then it took many many years for justice
to be done eventually it was the
Americans admitted that they had done
this and passed an amendment by senator
Feinstein Senator McCain saying once
again it's against the law
the Americans admit it we don't do this
anymore um one of the things that I find
so interesting about this project is
that Scott and all of you guys had to
make this thing in 26 days and there's a
ridiculous amount of dialogue that has
to be delivered in those 26 days he was
mentioning a lot of people were off-book
you know all the time could you I guess
could you talk a little bit about making
this in such a short period of time well
not only making it at such a short
period of time but but making a two-hour
movie about a 7,000 page document that
was distilled down into a 500 page
summary that was then distilled into a
hundred and thirty page script that was
then shot in 26 days so you need to have
a certain level of professionalism and
competence on both sides of the camera
and that what part of that was and that
was mentioning earlier that we spend a
lot of time around the table before we
started shooting so we've all the
questions that you ask when you're what
did I mean here or we we didn't have
those we've been asked and answered
already the parts of the script that
maybe didn't really work or didn't sound
right who had already read through those
and Scott could corrected those asked
and answered and we had Dan Jones on set
all
time so if there was anything you needed
to know you could go right to the source
and so that was what made it not I don't
want to say easy but certainly doable
completely I think I have to go um thank
you so much and seriously congrats on
the movie that's fantastic Thanks